dieses Gadget verspricht alle
Lebensmittel schneller schneiden zu
können als jeder Profikoch und was soll
ich sagen
es funktioniert
tiktok ist voll mit genau solchen Videos
und eine Frage bleibt dabei für mich
immer offen braucht man die Produkte
wirklich oder ist es einfach völliger
Müll genau das finden wir in diesem
Video heraus ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
mit Amazon Produkte testen
starten wir relativ einfachen Produkten
und es wird immer krasser ist wird immer
teurer und vor allem immer unglaublicher
denn ein zwei Produkte sind dabei bei
denen ich wirklich am Zweifel ob das
funktioniert kann dass das hier
funktioniert relativ eindeutig es ist im
Prinzip nur eine Silikonform die Liebe
Wasser füllen um eisige schrottgläser zu
machen was man daraus bringt es einem
selber überlassen ich rate euch
natürlich dringlich davon ab Alkohol zu
konsumieren deswegen befüllen Sie jetzt
tun sie ins Gefrierfach und schauen wie
gut und ob es tatsächlich funktioniert
ganz im Ernst ich bezweifel das ist
wirklich ein winning Produkt ist ganz
einfach wenn man natürlich auch die
Drinks kühlen kann und sich diesen
ganzen Stress dann nicht antun muss
vielleicht erwartet uns aber ja eine
positive Überraschung
wir sehen uns später im Video wieder und
während wir darauf warten bis die
schrottgläser zu Eis werden zu einem
reiseprodukt ist kleinen verpackt und
ausgepackt ist es doch so groß dieses
Format ist dadurch entstanden dass ich
die Videos gesehen habe und gedacht habe
eigentlich brauche ich rein gar nichts
davon und um euch davor zu bewahren die
Sachen selber zu kaufen und ins Klo zu
greifen teste ich sie und ihr bekommt
von mir eine ehrliche Meinung dazu
ich weiß nicht so recht was ich davon
halten soll aber das schreit nach einem
world Test
real worldsio wir befinden uns auf einer
extrem langen Autofahrt also perfekt um
dieses Ding hier zu testen ja aber zum
Vergleich ein normales Nackenkissen
mitgenommen und da schon kein wirklich
normales sondern eins
dass ich unter professionellen
Nackenkissen einstufen lässt das ist
nämlich hier vorne so zu machen und dann
abstellen dieses Kissen verspricht aber
noch viel mehr verspricht verschiedene
Möglichkeiten sich zu sitzen den Kopf
abzulegen und vor allem wirklich zur
Ruhe zu kommen auf fahrtenflügen und so
weiter gehen und komme mit einer sehr
genauen nie Faktor Bewertung aus dem
Kissen wieder raus gute Nacht
Aufstehen ist es ein Product dass wir
wirklich lieben absolut nicht ist es
geiler als ohne Kissen absolut ja und
deswegen landet das von mir genau in der
Mitte es ist ein Gadget mit Funktion
aber ohne Funktion die man zwingend
braucht es ist ein mietfaktor von fünf
von zehn aber vielleicht kann uns dieses
das nächste Gadget bei unserem Stopp bei
McDonald's mehr Abhilfe schaffen im
Prinzip besteht unser Gadget aus zwei
Teilen einmal eine Möglichkeit unsere
Pommes unsere Chicken McNuggets was auch
immer sicher in unserem Getränkehalter
im Auto zu positionieren also ziemlich
genau so und dazu das eigentlich
wirkliche Gadget weil im Prinzip könnte
man die Pommes natürlich auch einfach so
in den Getränkehalter Stellen dieses
Ding sichert eine sichere Benutzung der
Soßen im Auto während der Fahrt
natürlich nur als Beifahrer im Auto ab
dieses Ding wird in der Lüftung
positioniert und hier kommen die Soßen
rein
stellen wir uns vor wir werden jetzt auf
einer langen Autobahn Reise
und das hier drin positionieren
sehr wackelfest ist schon mal sehr gut
das ist perfekt positioniert ein
absoluter Traum die Soße ist tatsächlich
ein Problem bei bei langen Autofahrten
und das habe ich schon öfter selber
gemerkt und das hier soll jetzt die
perfekte Abhilfe sein in einem normalen
Auto würde man das jetzt hier in die
Lüftung stecken und hätte
die perfekte Möglichkeit in meinem Auto
ist es nur für die Beifahrer bzw für die
Leute auf den hinteren Sitzen möglich
oder für mich bei der Fahrt indem ich
mich einfach vom Verkehr wegdrehe dass
hier rein Dippe und nach drei Sekunden
ohne nach vorne geschaut zu haben das
Auto weiter Steuern funktioniert das ja
braucht man das NÖ habe ich trotzdem
gekauft ja nie Faktor eine Eins ich habe
dieses Ding gekauft aufgrund von einem
tiktok Video dass ich gesehen habe dass
mir wirklich die Sprache verschlagen hat
ich habe vergessen das Gefäß zu reinigen
und nach vier Tagen haben sich Maden
gebildet neben existieren in Matratzen
das ist einfach perfekt und das ist auch
nicht schön zu reden und eigentlich
dachte ich auch das ist nicht
wegzubekommen aber angeblich soll dieses
Ding das schaffen und genau das werden
wir jetzt mal testen und da ich und das
habe ich in einem der letzten Videos
auch schon gesagt neulich auf eine neue
Matratze gewechselt bin dachte ich
schauen wir was ich in der Matratze
verbirgt wie ich die letzten vier Jahre
genutzt habe bevor ich neulich meine
Matratze gewechselt habe also hier kommt
heiße Luft raus dann saugt ist und es
dreht sich schaut es euch an
jetzt mit den Milben der Kampf angesagt
[Musik]
das Ding ist genau dadurch dass dieses
Ding nicht ausgelernt wurde ist dieses
unheimlich ekelhafte Video entstanden
und so gut dass jetzt auch hier mit
geklappt hat glaube ich ist es keine
hundertprozentige Lösung die einzige
hundertprozentige Lösung gibt es mit
Emma dem Partner des heutigen Videos ich
selber bin zu Hause und in der
projektwohnung auf eine ma 25 Hybrid
umgestiegen und schwitze seitdem nicht
mehr beim Schlafen was lange Zeit ein
Problem von mir war ein Drittel unseres
Lebens verbringen wir im Bett deshalb
muss ich euch nicht erklären warum es so
wichtig ist wirklich gut zu schlafen und
dafür auch die richtigen Produkte zu
nutzen eben genau diese Matratze die
immer 25 Hybrid ist super easy zu
reinigen weil die Bezüge abnehmen war
sind das bedeutet ihr müsst nicht extra
so ein Gerät kaufen außerdem könnte die
Emma Produkte bis zu 100 Tagen komplett
risikofrei testen und das beste ihr
müsst nicht schleppen Versand und
Abholung sind komplett kostenlos neben
Matratzen bietet immer aber super viele
weitere Produkte an wie Kissen
Boxspringbetten Lattenroste einfach so
ziemlich alles was eine positive
Auswirkung auf euren Schlaf haben kann
mit dem Codes bekommt ihr 5% extra auf
das gesamte Amazon Sortiment auch auf
die Produkte schon bis zu 40% durch den
ostersiel reduziert sind der Code sleepy
day für 5% extra läuft ab heute 6 Monate
und der Oster sale endet schon am 10.04
haltet euch also ran wenn ihr euren
Schlaf verbessern und dabei Kohle sparen
wollt vielen Dank an immer für die
Unterstützung und euch viel Spaß weiter
mit dem Video wenn dieses Produkt so
funktioniert wie gedacht dann bin ich
wirklich begeistert ich meine wir kennen
das alle Mannschaft ist nicht man
braucht keine ganze Tomate irgendwas
bleibt liegen und man räumt das einfach
in den Kühlschrank und nach zwei Tagen
wenn man wieder Lust hat die Reste
weiter zu benutzen sind sie schlecht
oder zumindest nicht mehr so dass man
wirklich Lust hat sie weiter zu benutzen
und genau da sollen diese kleinen
Silikon Dinger Abhilfe schaffen wir
werden die eine Hälfte der Zitrone und
eben der Tomate mit diesen Silikon
Dingern bedecken und die andere offen
lassen so wie wir es normalerweise im
Kühlschrank liegen lassen würden um zu
beobachten ob diese Silikon Dinger
tatsächlich genau das tun was sie sollen
nämlich die Sachen länger frisch zu
halten wir sehen den wissenschaftlichen
Bereich von Max Kühlschrank den wir für
unseren Test missbrauchen Tomaten rein
die Zitronen rein
okay man sieht das ist schon ein
Unterschied macht aber im Prinzip wäre
auch die unabgedeckte Tomate und Zitrone
weiterhin noch zu benutzen absolut top
kann ich mir sogar wirklich vorstellen
in Zukunft weiter zu benutzen für mich
einen neuen von zehn meet wir bleiben in
der Küche für ein weiteres sehr
interessantes Produkt mit einem starken
versprechen und zwar sieht und
Salatschleuder in einem zu sein Platz zu
sparen in allen Küchen und äh das in
diesem wirklich sehr kompakten Format in
unserem Sieb können wir nicht nur Salat
machen sondern auch Nudeln abgießen und
viele andere tolle Dinge machen aber es
geht natürlich hier um die um die einzig
wahre Funktion genau die testen wir
jetzt
gedreht
und im Prinzip was das werden Feind
getrockneten Salat das alles in ziemlich
kleinem Format das ist für mich
mit ziemlich gute Idee und es
funktioniert für mich ist es eine ein
needfaktor von sieben vom 10 und endlich
kommen wir in eine Richtung in der die
Gadgets in irgendeiner Weise wirklich
nützlich sein können und vor allem
reusable so dass man sie nicht nur
einmal für den Witz benutzt sondern mit
tatsächlich langfristigem nutzen und
genau da kommt dieser Handwerker ins
Spiel nicht nur irgendein Handwärmer
sondern einer der retarable ist das
bedeutet sollte es kalt werden wir gehen
zwar Richtung Sommer aber sollte es
danach wieder kalt werden ist man
hiermit für alle kalten Tage gesichert
über diesen Knopf an der Seite schalten
wir das Gerät ein und können auf den
Grad genau scheinbar dieses Ding hier
jetzt einstellen also von 45 Grad
50 55 und das sind im Prinzip die drei
Stufen wir haben oben eine
Batterieanzeige und für Frostbeulen für
die Frostbeulen unter uns ist das schon
ziemlich cool gerade wenn man so jeden
Tag zur Schule gehen muss oder zur
Arbeit geht und man ein Problem mit
kalten Händen hat dann funktioniert das
richtig gut und deswegen wird sofort
wirklich richtig warm all in all
ziemlich cooles Produkt für den Preis
kann man das machen wenn man eine
Frostbeule ist es ist eine 6 von 10 in
meiner Situation es kann aber auch eine
acht oder eine 9 von 10 sein wenn ihr
Probleme mit Kälte habt das nächste
Produkt ziemlich klein aber
wahrscheinlich ziemlich Handy vor allem
für viele meiner Kollegen wenn ich so
deren Tastaturen gesehen habe dieses
Ding ist ein Staubsauger im
Taschenformat für alles was sich um den
Schreibtisch dreht also Mauspad Tastatur
und eben der gesamte Schreibtisch an
sich das Ding funktioniert schauen uns
jetzt mal an wir finden uns wieder am
Schreibtisch meines Lieblings Katas
Leonardo aggress hier passiert die
gesamte Magie heute Abend passiert dir
keine Magie mehr den Leo ist schon nach
Hause das ist eine Lüge der steht direkt
hinter der Kamera aber das ist der
perfekte Schreibtisch um das
auszuprobieren denn wie man hier sieht
diese Hygiene lässt etwas zu wünschen
übrig gerade beim Mauspad könnte man mal
versuchen inwiefern das in diesem real
world Beispiel funktioniert
[Musik]
also das hier ist im Prinzip die
Ausbeute das schreibtischstaubsaugers
also tatsächlich es funktioniert und
mindestens 10 Quadratzentimeter von Leos
Mauspad sind jetzt auch wieder sauber es
geht das ist eine coole kleine griffbare
Lösung direkt in Schreibtisch Nähe für
alle die gerne sehr hygienisch auf Ihrem
Schreibtisch sind ich glaube ich brauche
es nicht nie Skala von 6 und damit auf
zum nächsten Produkt glücklicherweise
hatten die shotgläser die wir am Anfang
ins Gefrierfach getan haben mittlerweile
genug Zeit auch wirklich einzufrieren
aber wer wären wir wenn wir die Hände
nicht befüllen müssen natürlich nicht
wir haben einen Gadget das abhilfe
schafft und zwar in Gadget das ist uns
erlaubt 6 Shots gleichzeitig zu befüllen
auch hier wieder ich gehe nicht davon
aus dass das irgendwer braucht aber zu
so einem Partykeller zu so einer Party
Ausstattung kann eben auch sowas gehört
ob es funktioniert das schauen wir uns
jetzt an im IP muss durch dieses Ding
halt nicht jeder schaut einzeln befüllt
werden sondern wir füllen hier oben
Flüssigkeit ein
das war's ich finde es cooler als
gedacht um ehrlich zu sein weil es geht
schnell es ist treffsicher und
der Geschmack stimmt auch
für mich kriegt das eine sechs von zehn
weil es nach wie vor ziemlich unnötig
ist und gefühlsmäßig das einzige was es
besser machen könnte wäre wenn das in
shotgläser laufen würde die das Getränk
automatisch kühlen und genau da schauen
wir jetzt was draus geworden ist unsere
Form sieht wunderbar aus was mich etwas
wundert wenn wir hier genauer hinschauen
auf der Oberfläche die eigentlich glatt
sein sollte und wo die Shots stehen
sollen ist naja so ein kleiner ein
kleiner Haken der vermutlich schwierig
macht das Ganze hinzustellen aber wir
schauen es uns einfach mal an feinster
Gläser ist gerade ich glaube nicht dass
wir irgendwas falsch gemacht haben naja
vielleicht funktioniert ja auch so
super aber das ganze natürlich nicht
alleine sondern nur Gesellschaft
max hat gerade einen richtigen Punkt
angeführt mit heißem Wasser beim heißes
Wasser eingefüllt hätten wäre das Eis
klar geworden aber schaut euch das mal
an ja also
schöner Gedanke
Punkt ich gebe Max recht schöner Gedanke
ein Produkt dass man nicht unbedingt
braucht aber es ist ein witziger
Partygag Ranking eine entspannte fünf
von zehn und genau damit endet das Video
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst mir
gerne ein Like da vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren vielen Dank an Emma
wir sehen uns in der nächsten Woche
wieder
[Musik]